[Music]
this is an example of when the law
doesn't really match the common sense of
the common person okay cool like you
can't [ __ ] your donkey in the bathtub
kind of yeah it's like these little like
weird um
can you explain a little more you know
how like they got those books that tell
you all these funny laws and [ __ ] yeah
like you could [ __ ] a donkey like in
your backyard but not in your bathtub
yeah like you're not arkansas or
something you can't be [ __ ] your dog
in
are they fact-checked for sure
there's like old laws that just never
disappeared because somebody made that
[ __ ]
a lot
because people were [ __ ] they're you
know i just respect that you guys are
still on the same page right away that
like that's just props and then we can
move on you always have a person to go
yup you're wrong
i've seen those books we read the same
books
same reading club i give it to them
after i'm done
so this is more on the lines of uh you
know when there's technicalities in
court cases you know like procedurally
they try to do everything so by the book
because if one thing [ __ ] up then it's
like the verdict is out the door yeah
jay simpson baby that [ __ ] yeah galen so
greatest judicial system on the planet
2014
a georgia father
accidentally left his kid in the car
while he did his shift at home depot or
something so his he had like a the kid
was like less than two while he did his
shift in the car seat for seven hours in
the car that sounds like a 1970s dad
though obviously the kid dies well is it
in arizona
uh
georgia no it's too hot
midday too hot
from what though
stroke
so then he gets sentenced to uh life in
prison
and then in
2022 oh [ __ ] the 17 got overturned what
why
it's the weirdest [ __ ] thing man so
like he got sentenced to life in prison
right but yeah what i didn't tell you is
that during the investigation they were
trying to figure out how the [ __ ] did
this dad leave his baby in the car right
so they uncovered a whole slew of other
weird [ __ ] uh they wanted to see what he
was searching on his computer during his
shift they found out that he actually
did google how long does it take for a
kid to die in a hot car jesus christ he
didn't google that he did google it oh
he did yeah
that's a search query and google said
you got about eight hours so he goes
cool i got seven it goes boss can i
leave it out early oh no uh so that was
one thing they found the rest of it they
found that uh he was chatting with and
sending nudes to underage girls
so that took precedence
there you go like let them out yeah so
they wanted that
key they're good so that's the key what
you just asked so like because that got
out during the trial
that wasn't supposed to be a prejudiced
thought in the mind of the juror whether
or not he was guilty for what he did
because he's a pedophile
because there's no way he would have
done that on purpose because he wanted
to [ __ ] that kid
which is his kid he wanted to go his
grooming he was grooming his kid
cheers
welcome back david welcome back
yeah you don't like slow cooked meats
you're telling me if i go [ __ ] rob
target right and the cops come and
they're like you [ __ ] go wrong [ __ ]
as soon as they handcuff me i'll go oh
yeah i got child porn like i gotta let
you go
we got we got another charges
copy's gonna go to jail for watching
john paul
you
[Laughter]
this guy did this you're guilty too [ __ ]
well how do you know i saw it too well
you're going to jail how do you know i
saw it too
don't go to jail guys
everybody's arrested everyone saw the
case
i didn't see it i saw it through a
mirror
and that's why in l.a we don't have any
cops anymore
too much child porn dude we [ __ ]
solve so much [ __ ] right now every juror
watching the case goes to jail too
why'd you look at the evidence like that
we're going to jail
why'd you lick your lips looking at the
video
did all 12 of you have to be jacking off
that naturality is they're arguing that
the jury was biased because they threw
that unnecessary piece of evidence like
this dad was too busy watching child
porn or no actually hooking up with
[ __ ] girls and then
what's his name chris hanson was they're
just catching so they just throw it out
because they totally found that as a
chance thing and what happens in that
case is that supposed to be tried as a
different thing
but the judge in this ruling allowed for
that to be included in the same trial
because it's like it's not extra credit
here right it doesn't count it's like
because they don't think it had anything
to do with leaving your baby in the car
to die i love america
for that yeah did he get tried yeah he
but he got life in prison for that but
because
justice was perverted during this
perversion they go oh hey welcome to
2022 where everything's super fair this
guy sends his overturn because that
shouldn't have happened
you know what um
america and so now he's inside for for
for child porn stuff but then now that's
only like five years instead of killing
this kid yeah which is life is that the
like controversy yeah they have to they
have to try him for that seven i have to
go to court again for this or or does he
have to go to court or is because he's
already thrown it's more like actual
double jeopardy where he was it was
already included so he can't get tried
again for it oh [ __ ] i'm afraid that
might be it but yeah that's like you
know things dude
i've been saying double jeopardy the
whole [ __ ] time i think i finally
used it right my head i was thinking
huh that's that that was the problem
i couldn't hear so many people talking
because they the jury didn't arrive to a
verdict unbiasedly
[ __ ] matter dude
like in that [ __ ] seafood city trying
to order [ __ ] in the wrong language
yeah dude it's um that's wild i should
do it csi [ __ ] dude tastes like one
[ __ ] uh ice cube confronted that guy
for being gay yeah
he's like i have relationships with
women i have sex with men hey guess what
that means you gay
lots of new information i guess
i spent hours here i learned [ __ ] and i
get dumber
so i guess that's the thing you got a
dead kid and a dude out of jail yeah and
you're not allowed to like uh you know
like let's say that uh that was the
problem is you can't go yes so this
[ __ ] guy left his baby in the car
well he was looking up young underage
women it's like you can't [ __ ] do
that you gotta go left his baby in the
car
the end so then why do people go
michael jackson his [ __ ] he touches kids
and his music sucks and it's like no it
doesn't why is that his music is good
his music is still in the chorus i love
joe bringing it back today like who
still listens to the art kelly dude when
the song comes on i play just ignition
did you put your head down after theirs
went up yeah
who would start kelly they went like
this
these two guys raised their hands i was
like yikes i'm in the wrong here
you know what i impose
nobody
that's [ __ ] funny to be the guy
asking but you don't even think that
he was raising his hand yeah i would
like this i went
i thought these two guys were like yikes
who's racist to some degree
you
hey when i get married though our
kelly's playing photo shoot
you have to ignition not at a wedding
does not make sense remix it's it's like
the remix and the cupid shuffle well
can't you just listen to a cover by some
other guy that didn't do it
that's a good work
[Laughter]
you know what i fantasize about so our
justice system is [ __ ] up right people
never get justice now
batman is a great idea but
you know guys running around [ __ ] bat
suits it's kind of ridiculous right i
think we should rebrand something that's
a little more asian but a little bit
more american let's call him aloha man
right
it will be like sherlock hawk or
something because he's british so he has
to be sure
create like avengers it'll be like you
know we'll have different crews right
but what we gotta do is like in every
area of america when there's justice
that wasn't served this character comes
out and [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of whoever
needs to be [ __ ] up
literally or figuratively who's cast it
in the asian avengers
oh simulu for sure for sure his
superpower is crying yeah and then we
have that
right up what's he mad
[Laughter]
is he personally upset with you he's mad
because i didn't like shane
that's why his super ability is crying
wow
do you know that no he he like openly
didn't like shang yeah yeah yeah and
then like i guess that news traveled all
the way to [ __ ] actual shang chi oh
he was so bad and then and then this guy
doubled down
and so he cried about it and now you're
making fun of him
had a good question about that what's
wrong with you not liking the movie
watch my two-hour podcast on it oh what
do you mean uh what's wrong with it
nothing exactly exactly that's the point
cause i do movie reviews on my podcast
and i reviewed it and i was very
disappointed because nothing personal to
seemu is just his critique on the movie
yeah i watched that movie three times in
theaters wow because i watched it you
didn't like it that much
well here's the thing i disliked it so
much in the beginning i was like maybe
i'm wrong right awesome maybe he's being
a new career chances are that's amazing
i respect that and i hate it even more
oh no the third one third one i was like
okay before i do a review on this i have
to figure out why exactly this bothers
me watch the third time and then i had
literally hundreds of pages of notes he
had a notebook wow
what's the number one thing that
bothered you
also
i mean watching it three times you don't
need a notebook it's so inherently bad
it's one of the worst marvel films that
have ever [ __ ] existed
wait wait more than doctor strange that
james was pretty weird doctor strange
was like decisively weird it's like more
than the eternals who do you believe
was worse the director or the writer i
like
what was the worst part about it well
the worst part about it too other than
his costume the costumes don't even get
started
with the costume
the the worst part about the film that
everybody has dazzled
is that they did a very terrible job in
making shang chi the main character
likable he was actually a very unlikable
person think about it like this right so
the main character who i actually think
is tony lung his father right yes he is
tony lung did an amazing job his father
his father sends his child lets him do
whatever the [ __ ] he wants right even
though he's like this drug lord whatever
or like this guy who's super powerful
allowed him to live his life however he
wants he abandons his sister who he says
his father's a terrible person he's the
[ __ ] you left your baby sister with
this guy who you called a monster right
and then suddenly he's this pious human
being my father's terrible you abandoned
your sister too so he didn't have a save
the cat moment basically he didn't have
to say because at all in the film so
check this out that's the emotional
struggle that he goes through right
isn't that intentional oh she'll
struggle because he had to save the cows
when they validate the car
oh my god
so stupid so check this out here's
here's another video the cat is i like
simu that's why i already know him the
worst part too is that after he meets
his father we're talking about a world
where this world is a world of mysticism
literally half the world disappeared
from a guy snapping his fingers his
father comes out gives him this idea he
goes look i'm from this magical world i
know your mother's still alive he goes
that's the dumbest [ __ ] thing i've
ever heard
that's a that's a fallacy in the writing
it's like how is it that in this world
that his father's saying there's a
chance that his mother's life is the
most ridiculous thing he's ever heard
makes absolutely no sense thanos
literally made the world disappear with
doing this
what 1970s gangsters do you know
half the world disappear i like you but
you're making this too real for me yeah
yeah yeah
he really was going like wow i like it
though
no no but this is true this is true
david blaine existing in that universe
and people going there's no [ __ ] way
we're not from no
[Laughter]
i could go with like seven more points
but it will take a super long time but
essentially what they didn't do
make him look good right because even at
the end point to when his father and him
are fighting they're literally fighting
because he thinks his wife's alive and
instead of him trying to rationalize to
his father he says that you were a
horrible husband your wife died because
of you it's like dude this character is
terrible like what the [ __ ] are you just
constantly blaming he's blaming he's
victim blaming constantly and top of
that he people's argument is that well
he was a terrible father well there's a
part in the film literally where shang
is hitting this wall constantly because
he's angry he's training and his dad
goes hey you need to stop that because
your mental health is even more
important than your physical health he
actually says the great dad my dad has
never said that
in asia
[Laughter]
i want that father
you